hey everyone i'm alan and welcome to my
channel where today i'm doing another q
a for
october it's october i don't know what's
happening to the year
and i don't like it this video is
sponsored by keeps we will hear more
from them in a moment
uh but for now just you know reading
questions if you want to ask questions
for the next q a leave them in the
comments of this one
that's how we do things very important
question to start with i get asked about
this a lot uh grant folger asked
this is for your next q a as an american
citizen who has been looking into
visiting australia for a possibly
extended period of time what are some
things i should know before i go
i'm out of focus are you okay webcam
first up
i don't feel like we warn people enough
you gotta watch out for dropbets
drop bears uh to get extra australian on
you
basically bears that live in trees
that drop they just sometimes just sort
of
jump out of the tree can really drop on
you do a lot of damage
um people always talk about the spider
and snake situation in australia but the
drop bears don't get a lot of coverage
look out for those it's a mess so just
any tall tree you're gonna want to keep
your eyes to the sky like you're playing
arc
reference not many people will get
otherwise i guess like major
differences between australia and
america are certainly etiquette
differences
australians are very laid back and i
think that that can probably come across
as
impolite we don't do the hi how can i
help you what do you need when we're
serving someone um
there's no tip and culture so people
aren't just overly
uh do you want to say accommodating
australia it's just very chill they're
like what can i get you mate cool
but mostly the thing that i said about
the drop is ralph hauser said what are
you looking forward to when things get
better again
what things are you referring to so many
things that could get better
you know i mean my main answer which is
a very uninteresting one
is i would really like to see my family
i would really like to go home
the issue in australia is pretty
complicated right now for anyone who
doesn't know for me to even
get home you in australia are mandated
to have a two-week lockdown
i believe the situation is they
literally pick you up from the airport
and take you to a hotel room and you are
locked inside for two weeks
it isn't a make sure you quarantine when
you get home
it is enforced um costs two or three
thousand dollars
so if i even went home for it to make
any sense i would probably want to go
home
for like months uh because i'm spending
my first two weeks
in a hotel as a prisoner by myself not
that my apartment is that much bigger
than a hotel
for being totally honest but you
basically can't go outdoors at all for a
full two weeks
and then i would get to see my family
and that's very complicated because
they're not letting people leave
australia right now if you're a citizen
obviously i'm not an american citizen
that becomes a whole thing
so yes number one i would just really
like to see my family
i love the ps3 said what's the first
game you'll play on your xbox series x
uh it's right here
right now actually you could you know
for proof if you would like i'm not
going to unplug it because it's plugged
in right now but we can
pull that out the back gotcha
proprietary uh what is the first game i
did play i tried to play forza horizon 4
um having just played it on xcloud and
needing to play more of that game anyway
it's like the first game in the forza
series that i just
haven't played enough of i really need
to currently not compatible
yeah i guess obviously the console's not
out yet so they're still working on a
lot of that stuff or or
uh up to updating the library which i
think is already like 1 200 games or
something
first game i ended up playing was fable
anniversary
um which was actually very nice for me
because i've been
a fan of the first fable specifically
the last chapters is my favorite for
such a long time
i finished it on the original xbox and
then i played it again
on the 360 and then it came with me to
the xbox one and the xbox one x i
streamed it not too long ago
and then it ended up being the first
game i played on the series x and the
performance was so much better
a lot of love for that game and it's
cool to just carry it with me
and then i played a little bit of re in
the world the wisps um i finished the
first chapter of tell me why i was
basically picking stuff that i had
already played for for comparative
purposes for the most part
but uh yeah using it every day having
having good experiences
liam 622 said with the images that have
surfaced recently just wondering if you
agree with the take that the ps5
is too big i assume you are referring to
images that are fake so for anyone who's
not seen this i feel like
it was very irresponsibly shared it uh
kind of
got shared on on twitter but uh it's an
image where the
the ps5 is augmented reality
dude i have this this has been so
annoying because it makes it really
difficult to sleep
and basically like
the underside of my foot is just
constantly twitching
just constantly like a like a little
twitch can you chill out dude
all right so i mean this one's really
obviously ar
so i can't find the actual one that i'm
looking for um but i feel like this is
an example
of of what's being discussed here is is
the ar model of the ps5
um i think has given people a bit of a
walk perception of basically i guess
this ar
that has has made there's this one
particular image that i wish i could
find it
made the ps5 look massive um it was
quite well edited so it didn't look
obviously like it was augmented reality
like that video does
but my perception on that is um look
that thing is really big and i could
totally you know have
egg on my face or whatever the phrase is
um when we
do see them in person next to the xbox
series x and it does look that big but
some of the things that people have been
seeing lately i think are falsified and
i think
the uh images the non-ar images um that
are based on actual measurements are
probably a much better
thing to go by do i think it's too big
uh they're both really big right so i
have to have the xbox series x
sideways in my tv cabinet i can't have
it standing upright i imagine i'm gonna
have the same case for the ps5 and yeah
well i do think they're large
and i certainly think the the ps5 is a
a weird-looking thing i didn't like the
the series x at first but now that i
have it i'm um
it it is pretty inconspicuous and i'm
cool with it changed my mind when i got
my hands on it so that could be the case
with ps5 as well but ultimately
if the design they made means the best
performance
with uh you know no overheating and
we're not gonna get
crazy loud fans which i know a lot of
people have had problems with the ps4 i
will say i don't have that issue because
i have the death stranding
ps pro which is one of the newest models
so like i didn't have that
sounds like it's going to take off when
you're playing last of us or goes to
sushima problem
but ultimately if it is large so that we
can accommodate
a new generation of better video games
uh that is probably not the right word
to use but you know
new tech things that run more smoothly
faster load times all that good stuff
then
so be it it's not something i'm i'm
caught up on at all i just like video
games
and now a word from our sponsor keeps
did you know
two out of three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they're 35
i should have said pattern with a hot
off sometimes the accent eludes me but
anyway
the best way to prevent hair loss is to
do something about it while you still
have hair you used to have to go to the
doctor's office for your hair loss
prescription but now thanks to keeps you
can visit a doctor online and get the
hair loss medication delivered right to
your home they make it easy and deliver
your medication every three months
so you can say goodbye to pharmacy
checkout lines awkward doctor visits
and having to go out in public at all
keeps office generic versions of the
only two
fda approved hair loss products out
there but yes keeps treatments typically
take between four to six months to see
results so it's important act fast and
the sooner you start using keeps the
more hair you can say
find out why keeps has more five star
reviews than any of its competitors and
why over 100
000 men just keeps for their hair loss
prevention medication so yeah if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss
go to keeps.com orlando pierce or click
the link in the description to receive
50 off your first order that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash alana pierce link in the
description
niko chunyi said will you at all be
going back to your other channel to make
more beats i would love to hear more if
you've already announced that you're not
then my apologies
so i have another youtube channel that's
just a lot of ps music where i've just
thrown some music up i don't promote it
i never link it anywhere
it's just there to have stuff on youtube
which i don't tend to do a lot most of
my
mixes are on soundcloud i only ever
upload things that i've played at
actual venues so those are all live
mixes that i played at clubs or venues
that i've been
paid to dj at because my setup at home
sucks
so the coronavirus certainly stopped
that one
but thank you for liking them i
appreciate it arms 27 what is your
favorite film and your favorite actor
hmm i think i've like changed my mind on
my favorite movie a few times
more recently but i think right now it's
actually hereditary
or a rival one of those two
favorite actor i really love tessa
thompson
i would say tessa thompson cameron
cityqueen said is your npc character and
cyberpunk 2077 stay in the game for a
short time
i've had people ask a lot of things
about my cyberpunk character request
i've said everything i can i'm not
allowed to tell you any quest details
whatsoever
stop asking if you can date me now dogs
cam said what do you think the is the
weirdest fact about yourself that you're
willing to share
i lived in a hotel for uh several years
my parents managed the hotel so
we had this like suite that was at the
top of it so i lived in a hotel
and it was a very cool thing as a kid
because i could go down to the kitchen
where you know we had chefs obviously
because the hotel had a restaurant in it
and they'd like make us cute desserts
and just we had like unlimited ice cream
it was it was very fun
and obviously outpour was the hotel pool
that we always had access to
i think i was in a commercial for the
hotel in the pool when i was like i
don't know
seven or something it was pretty it was
pretty neat it was pretty neat
but very weird don't understand that's
not most people don't have the
experience of literally their home being
a hotel
christian b said so hypothetically if
someone snapped their fingers thanos
style or removed the possibility of
being a games journalist or anything
similar what would you be doing instead
i am sure i've answered this before um
but it's writing i would be a writer i
don't know if you count that as anything
similar but maybe i'd be writing a tv
show maybe i'd be writing
books maybe i i mean i'm doing that
anyway i guess but currently it doesn't
do anything for me financially i'm just
doing it a lot in my spare time i've
finished quite a few short stories this
year actually but uh that is
my main two passions in life have always
been video games and writing
i like putting words on pages penny
santos said have you ever been arrested
before
no um good kid um
didn't get into a lot of trouble at
really any point in my life however
there was one instance where
i was doing something that i guess was
illegal that maybe i don't know maybe
i'm not that much of a good kid
me and a bunch of other friends were
hanging out at a school at night time
um just being kids hanging out
on a large oval it was actually my
primary school so
it was a school that i went to but i was
a teenager at the time and
cops did come we did get in trouble i
don't feel like i was arrested it wasn't
on a record
i wasn't handcuffed technically i was
driven home in a cop car
because i mean we were trespassing
ultimately and when i got home
they told my parents that we had been
caught there
and that there were like eggs nearby and
a bunch of houses had been eggs i am a
person who
is a vehemently against egging even when
i was a teenager
because i had this thought process again
even as a teenager
of somebody's parents spent potentially
millions of dollars and their entire
lives saving to buy this
if you don't like the shitty person who
lives in that house
why damage the property of an entire
family who's paying a mortgage and going
to work every single day
i was just like against it it's like we
don't egg okay we don't we don't do this
to people it's shitty
so then when the cops drove me home and
i went home i don't know it would have
been like maybe like 2 a.m or something
literally would just
from my perspective kids hanging out in
a park they told that to my parents
my parents were like they said you were
egging and i was like what and they were
like we didn't think so
i was like [ __ ] no the closest that i
ever got to egging someone's house
i don't remember what this person even
did i just knew my friends were very mad
at them
i talked them down from egging they want
to take the house i was like
don't think that we should do this i
maintain it's a shitty idea why you
gotta do that to her parents or whatever
so we ended this is so funny we ended up
flowering her like front fence
and we just we just bought bags of flour
and just threw flour everywhere
still not in theory ideal but i was like
it's not gonna rot the paint
or not making loud noises someone
doesn't have to scrape it off a window
you know so that's what i'm kids these
days flower houses
don't egg them think about people's
parents who work real hard it's not
their fault if their kid is a [ __ ]
and this is why i'm a very bad villain
in among us
trent lee said do you dislike patrick
brown can't tell if you're just mucking
around in the third degree
i love everyone at inside gaming every
single person at inside gaming
i love all of them to bits including
patrick brown no they're all
fantastic people rodrigo ortega asked do
you have a driver's license
i do i actually worked at a car yard for
several years and was the editor of a
car magazine for a while
well call website actually wasn't a
magazine and that is it for me today
everyone i hope everyone is doing
wonderful and having a good week
i thank you to keep subscribing this
video the link will be in the
description below if you want to check
that out and
uh oh my gosh i will see you guys next
time bye